Andy Grove who was a Hungarian immigrant entrepreneur,
one of the founders of Intel, the CEO of Intel,
he was known as the guy that drove the growth
phase of Silicon Valley.
I mean, this guy was respected among all CEOs.
Some people would have called him even bigger
than Steve Jobs.
Let me tell you, that's who Andy Grove is.
He wrote a book once called Only the Paranoid
Survive.
God bless his soul, he passed away early this
March, 2016, and those who knew who he was
and followed a lot of his content know the
industry lost a great man.
If you haven't read his book Only the Paranoid
Survive, even though it's an old book, I highly
recommend everybody read it.
The stories may not be relevant, but the concepts
will be relevant.
I wanted to produce a video because paranoia
is a very interesting topic.
A lot of people say it's good or not good
to be paranoid.
I think there are 10 things to be paranoid
about as an entrepreneur, that are very critical.
I think paranoia is absolutely necessary and
the ones who are the biggest thinkers are
usually the most paranoid entrepreneurs.
The smallest thinkers are normally the least
paranoid.
Now remember, I'm not talking about negative
paranoia, that everybody is out to get you
at the workplace and so you don't perform,
you don't talk, and you just kind of stay
in a corner by yourself - that's small thinking.
I'm talking big thinking paranoia, like a
general would to do say the enemy is going
to attack us from here, if they flanks us
here, we're good and protected, that's what
I'm talking about the level of paranoia.
So ten things, let's go through it.
#1: In my opinion, in no specific order these
are ten things.
#1: Speed of implementation.
Speed.
To me, speed is probably at the top of my
list of paranoia.
What do I mean by speed?
One, how quickly do we implement an idea that
we have that's very effective.
I'm paranoid on the speed of that.
Sometimes we're moving too quickly where it
become abrupt and we need to take our time
to be more diligent so we don't lose $728,000
on a project we're working on.
Right?
But speed regardless is by far at the top
of my list of things to be paranoid about.
Speed of delivery for customers.
Speed of delivery for partners, vendors.
Speed on how quickly we get back to a customer
or anybody.
Speed on emails.
Speed on placement.
Speed on purchases made, how long does it
take to make the purchase, how easy is it,
right?
How quickly does the next step happen for
the product to be sent to them?
How quickly, if it's a loan, underwriting.
If it's anything -- everything comes back
down to speed.
The biggest companies in the world that become
way, way too thick became very, very thick
because at one point speed was very critical
and they've been flat because speed is no
longer a priority to them, okay?
You've got to keep that in mind.
They forgot about the speed.
They forgot about being paranoid about the
speed.
#2: is time.
What is time?
Time could be many different things, but I'll
explain to you what I mean by time.
Time to me is one, we don't have as much time
on getting this done as we think we do.
Let's go get it done, right?
How much time will it take for this to be
done?
So am I being diligent on the amount of time
it takes for me to get this project done?
Or are we just winging it?
We had a project that the technology guy told
me is going to take 90 days.
Absolute lie to us and he got money, and everything
that was taking place, it's been nine months,
no delivery of a product.
I'm not happy about that.
Why did that take place?
Front end, there wasn't proper preparation
with this one developer that we hired and
we had to hire some other developer.
And this developer sold himself very well
on what we did.
I'd love to give his name away but I'm not
going to give his name away yet because if
he delivers he's fine.
But sometimes it's the development of a product.
Sometimes it's the time they say it's going
to take and it doesn't come through.
Sometimes it's someone telling us, "We can
only do it in 60 days," but they're lying.
Why?
We didn't ask enough questions.
We should have asked questions.
So I can't sit and blame.
I should have taken responsibility and asked
more questions and our team should have been
a little more diligent.
What can we do to be better with this time
part?
Another one with time could be how urgent
we are.
How urgent are we about getting the answer
to a question?
Why do we take two weeks to get the answer
to this question, why can't we get that question
answered within two hours?
Why don't we contact the people to get that
question answered today?
I want the answer to that question today.
So why is it taking such a long time to get
the question answered?
Even faster.
We needed these three people to hire, why
are we taking so much time?
We needed to hire this person over here, we
needed to get this vendor, how come we're
taking so much time?
That's the time part.
I'm paranoid about that part and I think entrepreneurs
who are not generally, everything becomes
lackadaisical and everybody else follows that
same exact culture.
#3: Kind of goes with number two is deadlines.
I'm paranoid about deadlines.
Are we going to hit this deadline?
Is this thing going to get done?
It's similar, but it's kind of not, because
time can be so general.
This is purely deadlines.
Being paranoid about deadlines being met.
You make an announcement that somethings going
to launch at this time, how paranoid are you
that this launch is going to take place?
How does the team feel about that deadline
not being met?
What are we doing about that part, right?
Paranoid about deadlines.
#4: Internal systems.
How efficient are your internal systems?
What type of product are your internal systems
producing?
Are your internal systems producing the best
type of product?
Is the experience the best type of experience
that it is producing?
What needs to be adjusted for it to be more
efficient, faster, more streamlined?
Is it duplicateable, is it something that
anybody can do?
Is it a system that if you hire another person
can come immediately and do exactly what that
person was doing for the last three and a
half years?
Do we have a system like that?
Is it a system in a way where we hire four
employees, read this manual, got it, a week
from now I can do the same exact thing.
Is there a system for that?
How efficient am I with the systems internally
where everything's going to be working good
together and it's smooth, there are no glitches.
How great is that system?
That's the system, right that you're paying
attention to?
The next one is is innovation.
There's a lot of paranoia in innovation because
again, big companies are not paranoid about
innovation because they don't ever think they'll
be passed up.
Big companies are typically extremely arrogant
and cocky and we're the best and we're gonna
this, and they're just more from there and
usually a younger company comes and says we're
not the best, we are not cocky, we're not
there yet, you are bigger than us, you are
better than us, but man, we're hungry.
And let's see who's going to win.
Ready, let's go fight.
Let's see who's going to do it because innovation,
speed, innovation, speed, improve, innovation,
innovation, innovation.
How can we improve?
A lot of this comes together and you've got
to be having a level of paranoia on whether
innovation is still taking place in your company,
or is it business as usual?
#6:Energy, I've talked about this a lot lately.
You know, studying all of the contentment,
how's your energy, do you still have the same
enthusiasm and excitement, are you getting
too content because you've had way too many
victories?
It's being paranoid about your own energy.
Is your energy still at the highest level
of energy where other people are wanting to
emulate and be around you?
Next, #7, paranoid about the most important
numbers and measures to study.
So a lot of times you have, as an entrepreneur,
you can measure hundreds of different numbers.
There are so many different things as an entrepreneur
you can measure.
So many of them.
But what's your number one?
What's your number one thing you measure the
most?
Just think about that?
Some people say, "The most important thing
to measure is profits?"
Why?
Because you're taking profits home?
You know, there's a guy that was working for
an attorney was telling me, "man, you know,
working for this guy who owns this law firm,
every month, profits come in and he takes
all the profits and leaves everything else
behind."
Well, if your profit is the most important
for you because you're only thinking about
yourself?
I don't know how many people are excited about
working for that company where the CEOs most
important thing is profits.
Now this doesn't mean that profits aren't
important because you're going to go out of
business.
Not at all.
Profits are important, but it's not number
one.
Is it top-line revenue?
Is it gross?
Is it paying off debt?
Is it being debt free?
Is it how much cash you have?
What is the measure?
Is it how many employees you have?
Is it how many vendors you have?
Is it how many partners you have?
How many products?
What is it?
To me, the most important measuring stick
is subscribership, to be paranoid about.
I spoke to a company that came and met with
me, and they said all this stuff that is taking
place with our company.
I said, "Tell me how is your subscription
going higher?
How many subscribers have increased?
How many?
How many users have increased?"
So, for instance, let's just say I'm a company
that was accustomed to having 1,000 sales
per month.
Hypothetically, I have 1,000 sales per month.
And that 1,000 sales was doing a million dollars
a month for me.
Let's just throw a number out there.
Now I'm doing 300 sales per month, but I'm
still doing 1.1 million dollars.
I'm very worried.
I am very paranoid.
But if I take that 1,000 customers that bought
from me -- they could have bought seven different
products -- but I want to know how many customers
bought from me.
1,000 users logged on and bought a product
from me and it's a million dollars?
I don't care about the million dollars, I
want to know how I can get the thousand customers
buying from me to 2,000 customers buying from
me, even if that million is 1.7 million and
it's not two million, I'm not worried.
I now have 2,000 customers.
Because I can always improve this.
But I can't improve subscribership.
This gives birth to everything else.
So I'm very paranoid about subscribership.
I am very paranoid about this area, to measure.
This gives birth to everything else.
What is your number one that you're most paranoid
about, every day that keeps you up at night,
that you wake up with every single morning.
Next one, #8, competition.
Competition really isn't at the top of my
list, but you've got to pay attention to your
competition.
You've got to pay attention to reading the
paper to see these people are coming out with
this, they're launching this product.
. . you've got to know.
Why?
Is it because everything you do is a reaction
based on what they do?
No, but you've got to kind of pay attention
to see what they're doing because they're
definitely paying attention to you as well.
How high is the level of paranoia on that?
Not that high, because if you're always - Napoleon
always said, they asked him, "which strategies
do you follow when it comes down to warfare?"
He said, "No one's.
I use my own."
Now that's Napoleon.
Everybody followed Napoleon's philosophy and
Alexander's philosophies, right?
Now secretly, he's probably copying somebody's
but Napoleon was about having certain philosophies
and action plans in place that maybe nobody
thought about, and everyone wanted to emulate
him, right?
But you've still got to pay attention to the
enemy, they have no 73,000 soldiers.
This army has 186 tanks, they have 62 jets,
and they have this much nuclear this, you
as a country have to know those things, in
the same way you've got to know your enemies
have as well at their disposal as much numbers
as you can get.
#9 - New laws and legislation - every industry,
real estate, insurance, finance, technology,
what are some regulations that are taking
place?
What are some things that maybe a new person
that's going to take an office, how's that
going to effect your business?
If this party takes over and that party takes
over, if this person gets elected, if that
person gets elected, you kind of need to know
a little bit about that.
Yes, you do.
You need to be educated about that because
if somebody's a front runner that's going
to be elected and they're telling you, "I'm
going to do this, this, this," and for instance,
imagine if I'm in the health insurance business.
And I know that Obamacare is coming up.
I spoke to a health-insurance guy yesterday
, 1,000 agents they have, and their business
has gone lower and lower, health insurance
has because it's just a complete different
ballgame.
So I'm speaking to health insurance companies,
those who were not prepared for Obamacare,
they took a very big hit.
Because Obamacare minimized insurance, commissions,
a lot of different things, and they lost competition,
they raised premiums 39%, I can't afford to
buy this and employees are dropping because
they can't afford so they're going with short-term
medical.
You've got to know that that legislation could
possibly effect your business.
If you don't, and you think, "Oh, it's not
going to happen," you've got to assume that
it is going to happen.
How are you going to react to it?
Every industry has laws and legislation that
you've got to be prepared for.
The great ones already have a plan of action
in case that does take place.
And the last one, let me tell you what the
last one is.
The last one to be paranoid about is your
leadership team.
A great coach is very paranoid about the energy
in the locker room.
A great coach is very paranoid about the captain
of the team that is leading everybody else.
What are his habits?
What is he doing when he's taking players
to his house or to dinners or parties, what
bad example is he teaching to them?
Well, maybe he's not the captain.
Maybe you've got to change the captain.
He could be the best player, but he's not
the captain.
Somebody else needs to be the captain.
The best player isn't necessarily the leader
of the team.
Remember that.
The best player is not necessarily the best
leader on the team.
It's very rarely the best player is also the
leader.
Very rarely.
So you've got to be paranoid about who you
put as the face of your company and who you
put leading everybody else because who you
choose may be the person that will give birth
to a lot of negative low standard type of
leaders, and you've got to be very, very,
very diligent about paying attention to that.
If you don't, standards will drop.
And typically, leaders who are not touching
everything, who are not on the road touching,
shaking people's hands, you generally don't
know everything that's taking place.
So those are 10 things that I have that I
would be paranoid with as an entrepreneur.
You may have other ones that I would love
to hear yours, you can comment on the bottom.
If you have any questions, about anything
I covered with you, you can also post a comment
on the bottom.
If you haven't read the book, Only the Paranoid
Survive by Andy Grove, I highly recommend
you read that book.
And if you're watching this video on a complete
different website, you can always come back
to PatrickBetDavid.com and you can have a
ton of content about entrepreneurship on PatrickBetDavid.com,
and last but not least, please be sure to
subscribe to this channel as well.
Thanks for watching, everybody.
Take care.
Bye bye.